bad news boys Emma Watson is self
partnered that's the new PC term for
single we will examine the left cult of
self-love then Kentucky goes blue sort
of maybe according to the mainstream
media the real election results are more
complicated so don't expect to hear
about them in the press we will analyze
what they mean for 2020 Rand Paul sheds
light on impeachment a new study shows
how politicized scholarship makes bad
public policy and ABC News covers up its
cover-up of the suicide of Jeffrey
Epstein who by the way didn't kill
himself all that more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
so much to get to today when the
mainstream media are covering up the
cover-up of their own cover-ups when the
mainstream media are lying about
politics I just want to tell them hey
guys go partner yourself you know just
go go somewhere and go partner yourself
that is the new PC term self partnership
that's what Emma Watson is describing as
the new way to be single you're not
single you're not alone you are the
partner of yourself I don't mean to make
fun of Emma Watson for this Emma Watson
was asked the question in Vogue magazine
she's approaching 30 years old now she's
not married doesn't have kids doesn't
have a house in the suburbs doesn't seem
settled down and so they say how do you
feel and she says she feels fine
she's not single she's self partnered
she said initially when she turned 29
she felt stressed and anxious due to the
bloody influx of subliminal messaging
quote if you've not built a home if you
do not have a husband if you do not have
a baby and you are turning 30 and you're
not in some incredibly secure stable
place in your career or you're still
figuring things out there's just this
incredible amount of anxiety I was like
this is what she's saying I'm not saying
I was like she says I was like this
whole thing about being happy and being
single
this is totally spiel it took me a long
time but I'm very happy being signal I
call it being self partnered I call it
being delusional we will examine where
Emma Watson goes wrong here and where
it's not just Emma Watson but where the
whole culture goes wrong on this cult of
self-love but first
speaking of loving yourself I've got to
get to Bolan Brand sheets because the
one way I really treat myself is I have
really luxurious sheets Boleyn branch
allows you to get extraordinarily high
quality sheets the kind of sheets you'd
get in a five-star hotel at home
everything Bolan branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton that means they
start out super soft they get even
softer over time now expensive
Sheetz I learned this when I registered
for my wedding expensive sheets don't
just cost like 50 bucks or a hundred
bucks ain't cost a thousand dollars if
you go to the store but by buying direct
from Mullen Ranch you cut out the
middleman you are essentially paying
wholesale prices so instead of paying a
thousand bucks in the store Bolan branch
sheets just cost just a couple hundred
bucks they feel incredible everyone who
tries Boleyn branch sheets loves them
that's why they have thousands of
five-star reviews I got mine and I said
there can't be any difference because
when I was a bachelor you know I would
sleep on sand paper basically I tried
them out and I thought oh this is the
difference this is how fancy people
sleep every night and especially if
you're like me and you spend at least
two-thirds of your life sleeping you
want to make sure that you have the best
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love Boleyn brand
sheets send them back for a refund but
you are not going to want to send them
back there is no risk there is no reason
not to give them a try get started right
now my listeners get $50 off your first
set of sheets go to Boleyn branch
dot-com promo code Michel mi CH AE L
that is Boleyn branch comm for $50 off
your first set of sheets Bo ll and
branch comm promo code Michael Boleyn
branch comm promo code Michael you are
going to love them Emma Watson is
partnered to herself other other words
mean she's single this is delusional
language and I understand why people are
using this language but you really
shouldn't because it's going to lead to
misery first of all I'm not saying
marriage is for everyone some of the
happiest people on earth are unmarried
there was a survey that what that went
around of the happiest jobs I think this
was in 2007 out of the University of
Chicago the happiest people in the world
the most job satisfied and fulfilled
people are actually celibate Catholic
priests so marriage is not for everybody
the plenty of religious people who are
unmarried who are very happy and for
people who are just happened to be
single they happen to be unmarried there
are ways to promote long term happiness
there was another study out of Harvard
it's one of the longest studies of adult
life ever conducted
it showed that relationships with your
family relationships with friends
relationships with a local community can
seriously promote long term
happiness even if you're unmarried or
you've never been married or you
divorced or you're a widow the
difference between all of those things
and being self partnered is the object
of your relationships because priests
are not self partnered priests are in a
relationship with God people who have
long term happiness and they're
unmarried are not self partnered they
have strong bonds to their communities
their family to friends to go in a
church to going to the local PTA going
to the local Lions Club whatever
marrying yourself self partnership all
different I mean we've seen self
marriage crop up in recent years not
just Dennis Rodman I mean Dennis Rodman
probably started this trend in the 1990s
when he declared himself bisexual put on
a wedding dress and said he was gonna
marry himself when Dennis Rodman did
that we all laughed about it we all
joked riving this was kind of a
ridiculous stunt now years later it's
actually happening you know two years
ago in 2017 a woman named Adriana Lima
married herself other women have done
this their stories about this crop up
all the time they call it so log of me
13 years ago so after Rodman but before
Adriana Lima a woman named Gil weds
herself and she said quote you're the
one constant your parents will die your
children will grow up and your friends
will move but you are always there I'm
not looking for the one I am the one
this is a recipe for misery it's not
just in self partnership it's not just
in self marriage you also see this in
sex robots especially if you read the
Drudge Report every day because I don't
know I don't know what Matt Drudge is
interested in on the internet but I do
know that every day there's a new story
about sex robots and it's not just Matt
Drudge it's there all over the
mainstream media because AI has
permitted sex robot technology to get
really really advanced so there was
there are no sex robot brothels there
were now sex robots that don't just move
their arms and do whatever sort of
things you want a sex robot to do they
actually have chest cavities that can
breathe they're actually simulating
human beings there they're really close
I mean mash
did a report on this the other day they
said that the robots are just as good as
people but they're not people they're
just hunks of metal and plastic but
people are I think mistakenly doing all
of these things these women who are
marrying themselves were people who were
buying sex robots or people who were
saying I'm partnered with myself I don't
need anybody
forget the feminist line from the 70s a
man a woman needs a man like a fish
needs a bicycle we can now say I need
anybody else like a fish needs a bicycle
I don't need anybody I need me I all I
need is myself I am perfectly sufficient
Emma Watson had that feminist campaign a
few years ago called he for she it's now
becoming me for me and that the idea
here I understand the idea there's a
loneliness epidemic that's going around
this country and around the West
generally loneliness is way way up there
was a study came out of Vice land it
surveyed young people it found out that
Millennials are more afraid of being
lonely than they are of losing a job or
losing a house that survey showed that
42% of millennial women are more afraid
of loneliness than they are of cancer
stress anxiety depression all up in
recent years antidepressant pills all up
people feeling very isolated and so they
turn to these these comforts what they
think are going to be comforts sex
robots or the idea of self-sufficiency
or internet porn which is just the same
thing as sex robots it's just you can't
touch it it's not it not as tangible but
it's the same idea and then ironically
when people turn to these things to
alleviate their loneliness they become
more isolated they become more withdrawn
why the reason is this culture of
self-love which you see all the time in
leftist publications you see it in Emma
Watson talking to Vogue magazine the
cult of self-love has deluded people
into confusing the virtue of endurance
with the sin of pride everybody is going
to be lonely sometimes it happens to
every single person multiple times
throughout their lives for sometimes
extended periods of time
it is a virtue to be able to endure that
loneliness and what we try to do is
mitigate the effects of that loneliness
by engaging with our community and by
praying to God and by involving
ourselves in the whole world very
different from the sin of pride which
tells us that we are sufficient unto
ourselves I don't need a partner I don't
need it but we're not human beings are
not self-sufficient it's even I think
sometimes conservatives want to lean a
little too much in this direction of
self-reliance and I don't need anybody
else I'll just go it alone but you
actually can't human beings are meant to
be in society together there is no such
thing as the state of nature where I'm a
single individual Adam just floating out
in the universe I'm born into a family
in a town in a society with customs and
traditions human beings are social
animals we are meant to be together
we're the political animal what is the
political animal politics is living
together with other people and
determining how you're going to live and
how you're going to govern yourself we
feel that and so we try to replace those
social bonds with virtual social bonds
digital virtual like partnering with
myself or marrying myself or looking at
internet porn or buying a sex robot that
I understand the suffering that comes
with it I think the people who are
saying these things are really trying
hard to make the best of a bad situation
but denial is not going to help anything
it's not compassionate to deny reality
and if we actually want to mitigate this
loneliness crisis that is affecting
everybody we have to stop pretending
that everything is okay we have to stop
pretending that it's fine to isolate
yourself from society and to take
yourself away from social bonds it's not
fine
you're not self-sufficient you're not
perfect that's just the way human nature
is and one way to mitigate that is to
work together and to recognize that
romantic love is not the only way to do
this but you need to involve yourself
you are not going to suffice not even a
Hollywood starlet like Emma Watson in
Emma Watson's
by the way she's a celebrity she's a
millennial and she's a former child star
the fact that she's not completely off
her rocker means she's turned out pretty
well she was dealt a very hard spiritual
hand here but it's a lesson for all of
us because we're all Millennials here
right we're all living in 2019 we're all
celebrities because we all have social
media
the problems that are being faced at the
pop culture level are problems that are
bleeding down into the rest of us
because we've had this huge leveling out
of of celebrity we've had this huge
leveling out of Fame in 2006 the Time
magazine Person of the Year was you
because of YouTube that's one of the
defining features of the era that we're
in and we need to make sure that we
don't fall into the same pitfalls of
celebrity which unfortunately it seems
that we are doing you know the cult of
self doesn't just show itself in how we
interact with ourselves
it even creeps out into the scientific
literature you know there is a group of
11,000 scientists right now who've
signed a petition demanding population
control demanding that we stop having
babies that we curb population growth
for allegedly scientific reasons we've
seen this before it comes from that same
cult of self we'll get to that in a
second then we'll get to election night
2019 but first I've got to thank our
friends over at wise foods during an
emergency it is very important to be
prepared you know just as I was leaving
my apartment this morning the power went
out
because we've had power outages over la
pretty frequently the recent fires were
another example I got evacuated from my
apartment I mean this this happens
regularly you want to be prepared you
cannot determine when a crisis will hit
but you can determine if you're gonna
have peace of mind when it does wise
company takes an innovative approach in
providing dependable simple and
affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before you
can get fresh fruit and water you can't
rely on someone else you have to rely on
yourself this is a good
is actually a good example where you
need to be a little self-reliant because
you can't count on emergency services to
get to you in time just give yourself
peace of mind this is how I think of it
I'm a man I'm not terribly organized I'm
not terribly thinking about I'm not
always think about everything that I
need to think about in the future get
wise foods their incredible quality and
then you don't have to think about it
anymore put it in the pantry and just
feel that in any way that you can lower
your level of stress I think that's a
good thing and if you can just diminish
that stress of what's gonna happen to my
family let it go
put it away when the apocalypse hits
you'll be good to go this week my
listeners can get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product at an extra twenty
five percent off the lowest marked price
at Weis food storage calm you've entered
Noel's canna wles and check out or you
can call eight five five four five three
twenty nine forty five plus shipping is
free Wise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy there is no risk in
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family more prepared today wise
food storage calm promo code normal
scanner wles get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product at an extra twenty
five percent off plus free shipping go
do it right now
because scientists are predicting
imminent emergency and one way that they
want to deal with this is population
control eleven thousand scientists right
quote we declare with more than eleven
thousand scientists signatories from
around the world clearly and
unequivocally that planet Earth is
facing a climate emergency to secure a
sustainable future we must change how we
live in ways that improve the vital
signs summarized by our graphs economic
and population growth are among the most
important drivers and increases in
carbon dioxide emissions from fossil
fuel combustion therefore we need bold
and drastic transformations regarding
economic and population policies still
increasing by roughly 80 million per
people per year or more than 200,000 per
day the world population must be
stabilized and ideally gradually reduced
within a framework that it ensures
social integrity there are proven and
effective policies that strength
Human Rights while lowering fertility
rates and lessening the impacts of
population growth on GHG emissions and
biodiversity loss these policies make
family planning services available to
all people it goes on you get the point
stop having babies start using condoms
and maybe abortion - to stop the weather
or something this isn't the first time
we heard this in 1970 Paul Ehrlich who
is currently a professor at Stanford
predicted that within ten years you
would see mass starvation unless we
curbed the population and this was this
was going to be caused by not just the
change in climate but by the earth not
being able to sustain all those people
he said within ten years we'll have a
hundred to 200 million people dying
regularly starving to death because of
overpopulation therefore you need to cut
your population in 1970 the population
was 3.7 billion on earth the population
today is twice that we are better fed we
are healthier than ever before it just
didn't happen
was there any consequence to this
leading scientist at Stanford University
no of course not
the scientists also in 1970 were
predicting global cooling they said our
warm epoch is undoubtedly over there was
a scientific consensus about this then
the consensus was wrong one thing I
noticed about all these disparate
political issues and these are political
issues by the way is that they come
together to thwart human flourishing
have fewer babies kill the babies that
you've got don't drive this don't fly
here don't build that don't do anything
stop flourishing for no reason they put
it in the name of science but they're
using science as though it were religion
and like many religions it's had many
false prophecies and false prophets even
on this issue that's a pretty wicked
religion that tells you to stop having
babies to kill the babies that you have
to stop flourishing when you
examine religions whenever you see that
that's just a little mark that tells you
hmm maybe this is not the way to go it's
part of that same cult of self that says
we need to prioritize us we can't pass
life along I know what we received life
as a gift but we can't pass it along
because the weather gods will be really
angry so let's just live for us right
now and nobody else that is a pathway to
misery you will not be happy if you live
only for yourself you will be much
happier if you live for someone else I'm
very skeptical of the social science of
happiness but all the surveys all the
studies we've got say that that is the
case there was one study that tried to
refute it said that single childless
women are the happiest people on earth
this was immediately debunked when this
story came out this year there's really
no evidence of that we are happy when we
involve ourselves when we encourage life
when we encourage flourishing and don't
believe anybody who tells you otherwise
whether it's a Hollywood celebrity or a
politician masquerading as a scientist
speaking of politicians let's get to
election night 2019 Kentucky goes blue
sort of maybe the Democratic candidate
for governor of Kentucky is declaring
victory here he is tonight voters in
Kentucky sent a message loud and clear
for everyone to hear it's a message that
says our elections don't have to be
about right versus left they are still
about right versus wrong that our values
and how we treat each other is still
more important than our party that
what's unites us as Kentuckians is still
stronger than any national divisions
that is Andy Beshear who's declared
victory as the governor of Kentucky
apparently doing the worst impression of
a politician I've ever seen did that guy
say anything that could not just be in a
cartoon of a politician our politics is
not about right versus left but right
versus wrong
am i right am i right do you get it we
need to prioritize principles not party
huh am i right we need to speak in
platitudes not serious statements I mean
just the most empty suit impression of a
politician I've ever seen the guy makes
Mitt Romney look like Winston Churchill
goodness gracious me
he is declaring victory now the
mainstream media of course are declaring
him the victor the Republican is not
conceding why because at last count the
two candidates were separated by between
five and ten thousand votes so so close
that's what 99% of precincts reporting
you have Bashar leading with that 49.4%
Bevin Matt Bevin who was the Republican
governor has 48.7% so very very close
election and Bevin is gonna gonna try to
hold on this is being reported on as a
major loss for Trump Kentucky of all
places goes blue turnout in this
election was higher than expected it's
estimated to have been around 1.4
million so that's roughly 400,000 more
than the last governor's race in 2015
there are some lessons here for 2020 the
silver lining is that Matt Bevin the
current governor of Kentucky is one of
the least popular governors in the
country that was according to a morning
consult poll this is in part because of
his history of incendiary comments and
big fights over public teacher unions
and healthcare the bad news for Trump is
because Bevin was such an unpopular
governor they called in the president to
try to help him eke out an election
victory the night before the election
and it looks like he's still lost so
this is reflecting very poorly on
President Trump Trump predicted it he
said don't don't let me lose tomorrow
don't let Bevin lose and then the media
is gonna say it's a big loss for for the
Trump administration now obviously both
sides are gonna spin this Democrats are
gonna say this is a bellwether this is
showing a blue wave for 2020 the
Republicans are gonna say Bevin was it
terribly unpopular governor that's why
Trump had to come out in the first place
and they're still going to be debating
who won the election anyway that's gonna
go on for weeks
the good news here is the Republican
Daniel Cameron was elected the Attorney
General he's also Kentucky's first black
Attorney General so he's a much better
politician he looks better he talks
better he's got a lot less baggage so
that's some good news shows it's not a
blue wave in Kentucky or anything like
that Cameron is a 33 year old first-time
candidates from Louisville
he got 57% of the vote when the AAP
first called the race in his favor he
beat the Democrat Greg Stumbo outside of
Kentucky if you look at Virginia bad
news for the GOP in Virginia the GOP
lost the Virginia State Senate so the
GOP was holding the state Senate by one
vote then the Democrats flipped the
state Senate still there's some good
news in Virginia as well Nick Freitas
who is a member of the Virginia House of
Delegates he won his election as a
write-in candidate so he withdrew from
the election formally in July because he
failed to submit the required paperwork
and then he ran a write-in campaign and
as a write-in campaign he beat the
Democrat by 14 percentage points at the
last count so this brings up a question
was it a good night or bad night for
Republicans was a good night bad night
for Trump should Trump have laid off it
was Trump a political asset or a
political liability in this election
you're gonna hear over the next few days
a lot of people say Trump was a huge
liability he dragged down the Kentucky
governors race
I think that's BS I think the Kentucky
governor was headed for a defeat and
Trump went in to try to try to stop the
bleeding but fair question when Trump
involves himself in races does that help
or hurt the candidates you've heard both
sides I think generally speaking Trump
is an asset in these races I'll tell you
why in a second but first we got to
thank our friends over at brickHouse
have you ever wondered why so many
Americans are sick unhealthy and
overweight I'll tell you why I'm
frequently sick as because I travel all
the time and I never sleep another
reason why Americans generally are are
unhealthy is because of the food supply
and because of a sedentary lifestyle it
leaves Americans in the worst shape
they've ever been in
that's why the team of on staff
physicians at brickHouse nutrition
created field of greens field of greens
is an easy way for you to add fruits and
vegetables to your daily routine without
spending hours in the produce section or
without hiring a home chef or taking
cheap supplements field of greens the
thing I really love about them it's made
with real usda organic fruits and
vegetables it's not some weird bizarre
extract super chemical I don't know it's
real food and it helps boost your
immunity using antioxidants and assists
digestive health with probiotics and
prebiotics it's like having a doctor and
a nutritionist in your kitchen one scoop
delivers a full serving of fruits and
vegetables now if you're like me your
diet consists of 80% fatty Italian meats
and 20% cheese that's kind of and maybe
a little bit of pasta it's the closest
thing to a vegetable I usually eat just
drop it a cup of water drop in field of
greens stir it you're done you will get
your servings of fruit and vegetables
it's also great for smoothies bottom
line here this is real food this is not
extracts you will look better you will
feel better I love it I don't I wouldn't
get my daily fruits and veggies
otherwise go to brick house nola.com
brick house Knowles it's gonna be my new
nickname brick house Knowles that's the
website get 15% off your first order
just for trying it out with the promo
code Knowles that's right trust your pal
good old brick house Knowles and go to
brick house Knowles calm promo code
Knowles you will love it is Trump a
political asset or a political liability
in these races and what's that gonna
mean for 2020 I think generally speaking
he's an asset and Scott Adams the
Dilbert guy tends to agree he thinks
that the conventional wisdom the wisdom
that we hear from the prognosticators on
TV who almost always get their
predictions wrong but we're completely
wrong about the 2016 election the wisdom
they espoused that President Trump needs
to just shut up and stop interfering in
politics that that's all BS because the
people feel a personal connection to
their president here's Scott Adams the
funny thing about it is when he first
our
tweeting during when he was running for
president people so that's too much
tweeting too much tweeting you'll never
get ok you got elected president but now
you need to stop and then he just
increases his tweeting and I think
historians are gonna say ok that
tweeting was a really good idea it
bonded the public to him without the
middleman and I think even the typos end
up working in his favor because you
because you know he wrote it that makes
it feel personal and it feels you feel
connected to your leader in a way we
never happy yeah it's being reported
that some of his staff wanted to
restrain him they wanted to read the
tweets before 15 minutes 50 minutes
exactly that would ruined everything
because I think you could tell a massage
tweet versus an original you look at he
go oh yeah you wrote that one so Scott
Adams has who's one of the few people
who predicted the Trump victory in 2016
and he predicted it by not because he's
this rock-ribbed conservative but
because he's spent a lot of his life
studying the art of persuasion and he
felt the Trump was doing a good job at
persuading people I love the point he's
making here as I hear this all the time
especially from the really smart people
who wear suits and ties and go on
television and predict politics and who
usually get politics wrong but who still
get invited on and predict more about
politics these are people who said Trump
was gonna lose who said his candidacy
was awful who said he'd never connect
with voters and then he won and he won
by being Donald Trump and by tweeting
and by talking and by being who he is
and then the people who were completely
wrong about the election say okay yeah
we were wrong and he won but now he's
got to do what we said I know that he
won the presidency by not doing what we
say he should do and other candidates
have lost the presidency by doing what
we say that he should do but now because
we're smart and we were suits and ties
he's got to do what we say no I don't
think so this whole idea that Trump is
some bumbling fumbling idiot who's never
done anything right who just happened by
happenstance was able to succeed in
every single thing he's ever tried is so
presumptuous it's such an arrogant point
of view here's my view of Trump
and here's my view looking at the 2020
election maybe the guy who became a
billionaire real estate developer who's
been famous since the 1980s who's been
at the top of the pop culture since the
1980s who branded his name on every
everything in the world who was a casino
mogul who was a merchandising mogul who
became the number one star of network
television for 15 years and who became
the leader of the free world elected
president of the United States on his
first actual run for political office
maybe that guy has some idea what he's
doing that's it that's my in my humble
opinion that's my modest suggestion here
maybe he knows what he's doing maybe all
these other people who were wrong all
the time maybe they're not quite as
certain as they seem to be maybe they
aren't all that much smarter than the
president that's what 2020 looks like to
me I think election night 2019 tells us
very little Republicans won some things
Democrats won some things Democrats won
the Kentucky governorship that's bad
that's too bad Kentucky's a conservative
state but the governor candidate was a
really weak candidate that's why he had
to call in the President of the United
States day before the election in the
first place I don't think it tells us
very much and so much is going to change
as we move forward into 2020 one big
thing is impeachment compete not just
impeachment but the IG report the John
Durham investigation questions about
interference in the 2016 election and
collusion between Democrats the federal
bureaucracy and foreign intelligence
sources so many more questions are going
to come up and the people who are saying
president Trump shut up don't interfere
don't speak I think they're missing an
essential point which is that the
mainstream media are the problem the
leftist establishment are the problem
and if Trump hadn't spoken up and cut
through all that they would have
succeeded in rigging the 2016 election I
think that's good it got to be our our
guiding light here not these little
races in Kentucky or Virginia and the
Republicans win some and Democrat
when some in 2019 but the 2016
presidential election that's going to be
the guiding light for the 2020 election
so how should Trump run it is he gonna
run it as MIT Romney is he gonna run it
as a quiet mild-mannered candidate no of
course not he would never get elected
that way and we've run candidates like
that before and they've lost he's got a
run for better or worse as Donald Trump
that's the guy who got elected that's
the guy he is he's not going to be
anybody else and I think it's going to
bring people along the idea that it just
turns off everybody that he's brash and
that he says crude things and he makes
crude remarks about women sometimes is I
think myopic it doesn't give enough
respect to the American people I mean
even even people who personally really
don't like Trump or defending him right
now you see this in punditry you see
this in politics you see this even with
family members I've been Rand Paul
Senator Rand Paul no love lost is now
defending President Trump more than just
about anybody we'll get to that in a
second we'll get to what it means we'll
also get to what faulty politicized
science does to our politics and finally
the journalistic standards of ABC in the
cover-up of the cover-up of the cover-up
of the jep's Jeffrey Epstein story
Jeffrey Epstein by the way he's that guy
who definitely didn't kill himself
you'll get all of that but you got to go
to daily wire.com
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me at the end or
Clavin sure you get the mount wall sure
you get the Ben Shapiro show did I say
that one you get backstage you get to
ask questions in the mail back coming up
tomorrow so get your questions in you
get another Kingdom the third and final
season and it's my favorite season yet I
really really enjoy you guys I think
you're gonna love it too most
importantly you get the leftist tears
tumblr mmm delicious as always head on
over to daily wire.com we'll be right
back with a lot more
so you've got impeachment is the
backdrop to the 2020 presidential
election nobody really understands why
Trump is being impeached in the first
place
nobody really it's not Russia it's not
stormy Daniels it's not the taxes I
guess it's Ukraine what did he do in
Ukraine they're accusing him of engaging
in a quid pro quo because he asked
Ukraine to investigate Joe Biden who's
the leading Democrat former vice
president who apparently engaged in a
quid pro quo
to get his son off the hook for
corruption because he was being paid
$600,000 a year with no experience
whatsoever to sit on the board of the
Ukrainian energy company which was a
major talking point at the State
Department we just saw in leaked emails
wow that's pretty complicated we need to
impeach Trump because he did what Vice
President Biden did Biden who's now the
leading Democratic candidate for
president hmm not doesn't hold up very
well Rand Paul is cutting through all of
the BS because at the bottom of this
impeachment inquiry is a whistleblower a
so-called whistleblower who is creating
the pretext for impeachment in the first
place
and Rand Paul is demanding that we find
out the identity of this whistleblower
we bring it into the light of public
discourse and we see if there are any
political motivations behind the very
root cause of engagement in the first
place whistle blower laws though they
protect a whistleblower you know it's
illegal to out a whistleblower so you
got that wrong too I mean we should work
on the facts here's the thing is the
whistleblower statute protects the
whistleblower from having his name
revealed by the inspector general even
the New York Times admits that no one
else is under any legal obligation the
other point and you need to be very
careful if you really are interested in
the news is that the whistleblower
actually is a material witness
completely separate from being the
whistleblower because he worked for Joe
Biden he worked for Joe Biden at the
same time hunter Biden was receiving
$50,000 a month so the investigation
into the corruption of hunter Biden
involves this whistleblower because he
was there at the time
did he bring up the conflict of interest
was there discussion of this what was
his involvement with the relationship
between Joe Biden and the prosecutor
there's a lot of questions that
whistleblower needs dance boom even if
they don't totally unmask the
whistleblower Rand Paul has just
unmasked the key feature here which is
that the whistleblower who I think is a
2008 Yale grad named Eric charmella and
he worked for John Brennan who hates
Trump he worked for the CIA and
crucially he worked for Joe Biden at the
time that all these shenanigans were
going on in the Ukraine not only is he
not a whistleblower not only is he
obviously a Democrat hack this was not
just my conclusion was the conclusion of
the Inspector General for the
intelligence community who found three
pieces of evidence that he was biased
against President Trump but he actually
would be a witness in the case here what
he's doing is he's blowing the whistle
on President Trump for trying to
investigate potential crimes that Joe
Biden engaged in a quid pro quo in
Ukraine so he's actually participating
in this at the same time of course his
identity should be revealed of course he
should be called to to account of course
president Trump should be able to face
his accuser this is from Rand Paul Rand
Paul is not some guy who carries water
for Donald Trump Rand Paul personally it
would seem despises Donald Trump they
had an incredibly acrimonious
relationship during the 2016 campaign
just to refresh your memory here is a
thing a second GOP primary debate in
2016 when Donald Trump insulted Rand
Paul's face
first of all Rand Paul shouldn't even be
on this stage he's number 11 he's got 1%
in the polls and how he got up here
there's far too many people anyway as
far as temperament and we all know that
I kind of have to laugh when I think hmm
sounds like a non sequitur he was asked
whether or not he would be capable and
it would be in good hands to be in
charge of the nuclear weapons and all of
a sudden there's a sideways attack it
mean I think that really goes to really
the judgment do we want some with that
kind of character that kind of careless
language to be negotiating with
but we want someone like that to be
negotiating with Iran I think really
there's a sophomoric quality that is
entertaining about mr. Trump but I am
worried I'm very concerned about him
having him in charge of the nuclear
weapons because I think his response his
visceral response to attack people on
their appearance short tall fat ugly my
goodness that happened in junior high
are we not way above that would we not
all be worried to have someone like that
in charge of the nuclear subject mr.
Trump I never attacked him on his look
and believe me this plenty of subject
matter right there he opens up is a
statement in 2016 and he says Rand Paul
shouldn't even be on this stage Rand
Paul says what are you attacking me for
he goes well at least I'm not attacking
how ugly you are these are guys who
don't have a great personal relationship
necessarily and even Rand Paul is
defending him because the deck is so
absurdly stacked against Trump right now
from the federal bureaucracy from the
Obama administration from the left-wing
media all of these guys are stacking the
deck against Trump so you're gonna hear
a lot of think pieces ironically named
think pieces they're not very thoughtful
in the next few days about how the
election night 2019 is evidence of a
blue wave I just wouldn't believe it I
don't I don't think it's evidence that
Trump is gonna win either I don't think
it's evidence of very much at all it's
going to come down to Trump it's gonna
come down to Trump himself not some guy
in Kentucky not some guy in Virginia
it's going to come down to do people
like how Trump is governing are people
willing to ignore some of the personal
flaws that that they find in the guy
he's not gonna win by pretending to be
somebody else he's not gonna win by not
being himself it's going to be an
election about Donald Trump and I just
think is a little bit of evidence that
people are gonna come around on him the
people are more nuanced in their
thinking then a lot of pundits give them
credit for I hear it not just from Rand
Paul who more or less says I don't
really like the guy but he's getting a
raw deal and he's a good president I
hear it from members of my family I hear
it from friends who say yeah the tweets
you know and I grade whatever the way he
talks but he's doing a good job I hear
from
we're drivers I hear from people on the
street I suspect that's going to be the
calculus in 2020 and it's not going to
come down to Kentucky and it's not going
to come down to what the mainstream
media tell you there is and we talked
about this a little bit yesterday this
is switching gears from the national to
the local level back to lala land where
I live
intensity USA the mayor of Los Angeles
said yesterday or we played the clip
yesterday said it a few days earlier
with a straight face he said that Los
Angeles is the model city for dealing
with homelessness which is absurd
homelessness increased in LA County 13%
from 2017 to 2018 increased in LA City
16% the homeless are everywhere here
there on the street there are a whole
tent set like actual tent cities
cropping up all around Los Angeles which
are full of drugs which are full of
violence which are full of sexual
assaults they're just hideous hideous
awful places that no one should be
permitted to live in and no one should
be expected to live in how did we get
here
the way we got here in many ways was
because of the closing of the insane
asylums huge numbers of these homeless
people have mental health problems or
drug addiction or both and they're
dealing with the mental health problems
with drug addiction a lot of this came
because we closed the mental hospitals
there's actually a new study a study of
a study that came out just last week
which shows that the science behind
clothing closing the mental health
hospitals was bunk was garbage 1973
david rosenhan psychologist published a
paper called on being sane in insane
places this was in the prestigious
journal science and it made a huge
splash the study showed eight healthy
volunteers going undercover as as fake
patients in 12 psychiatric hospitals
around the country and it showed the
awful conditions that they were in and
it showed how easy it was for sane
people to be locked up and it helped
push along this idea that we need to
click close all the mental hospitals
people blame Ronald Reagan for this
because Reagan was the Governor of
California and Reagan did help this
along but this was a liberal
this was always a left-wing policy that
that Reagan encouraged I mean Reagan
also made no-fault divorce easier and
liberalized abortion laws well he was
governor of California nobody considers
those conservative policies now it turns
out that the study that led to the
closing these mental hospitals was just
BS it turns out that a lot of resin
hands work was falsified that he
misrepresented and outright lied about
some of what he did that he actually
kind of masqueraded as a patient himself
and covered up the all of the other
symptoms that that these guys were
describing to the doctors of these
mental hospitals to get themselves
admitted to it it was bunk now we closed
the mental hospitals and now we have a
major homelessness problem this too gets
back to the cult of self-love no serious
society no respectable society should
permit 60,000 people on the streets of
LA to live in squalor and addiction and
filth and crime it is barbarous it is
completely uncivilized how do you stop
that the way you stop it is by dragging
homeless people to homeless shelters
half more than half of the homeless
shelters in LA are not filled every
single night there's a study about that
just recently well over half of them not
filled the homeless shelters in LA are
supposed to be at ninety percent
capacity they're at average 78 percent
capacity they're not being filled for
the homeless people who won't go to the
shelters they should be dragged to
either addiction recovery places or they
should be dragged to insane asylums
and they should be committed
involuntarily it's very hard to do that
now because of the laws but they should
and they and they should have that
happen because that's much more
compassionate than letting people live
on the street by the way if they won't
do any of those things they should be
thrown in jail because even that is more
compassionate than letting people live
in squalor and filth on the street and
crime and allow crime to spread
throughout the city and filth and
ugliness the way that we came to the
conclusion that it was more
compassionate to let people live on the
street is because we atomized ourselves
it actually gets back to that cult of
self-love we thought hmmm people should
just be allowed to do whatever they want
not my problem I feel icky forcing
addicts and unwell people into these
insane asylums so we'll just let them
out and not my problem it's their
problem I'll look away when I see them
on the street I don't need to give them
money look I pay my taxes I don't need
to give them charity and that's fine
it's not fun it's not compassionate it's
it's only considered compassionate in
this highly individualized highly
atomistic society that says I'm an
island unto myself I am NOT my brother's
keeper but of course we are we are
social beings we live with one another
we cannot tolerate this to persist
there's nothing conservative
there's nothing compassionate there's
nothing liberal about letting that
happen we need to take a much more
serious understanding of compassion of
love of self care of all of these things
that is the only way that we are going
to move ahead it's the only way that we
are going to ameliorate our situation
not just for the people who are on the
street but for ourselves as well the
only way that we're going to mitigate
this loneliness epidemic the stress
epidemic the depression the anxiety all
the only way we're going to turn this
around is by thinking not less of
ourselves but thinking of ourselves less
to quote CS Lewis that's going to be a
real way to engage in self love and self
care and it's through not selfishness
but selflessness
before we go I just have to point out we
talked about the Jeffrey Epstein story
yesterday Jeffrey Epstein is a financier
in a sex criminal who definitely didn't
kill himself so there was that bombshell
video from James O'Keefe which showed
that ABC News buried the James the the
Jeffrey Epstein story for three years
would not let any of it be reported for
three years once this undercover video
came out a BBC released a statement he
said at the time not all of our
reporting met our standards to air but
we never stopped investigating ever
since we've had a team on this
investigation and substantial resources
dedicated to
didn't meet our journalistic standards
this is ABC News which aired baseless
smears based on nothing against Brett
Kavanaugh this is ABC News which ran
footage from a 2017 Kentucky gun show
and pretended that it was currently
occurring in Syria from the Turkish
forces against the Kurds that happened
just a few weeks ago
ABC News which has no journalistic
standards whatsoever is trying to cover
up their cover-up of Jeffrey Epstein by
saying the Epstein story didn't meet
their journalistic standards be s call
them out for it
they're not they didn't air any any word
about this on their ABC Evening News
they're trying to cover it up again the
only way you cut through that is through
the means it's through the new media
it's through that internet culture
that's the way to do it and you've got
to try to keep this story alive about
Jeffrey Epstein who is not alive because
he didn't kill himself but was obviously
killed intentionally that's the meme
that's the show go engage in a little
self-love but not by self partnering go
engage in a little self-love by
involving yourself in the world and then
come back and I'll see you tomorrow
get your mailbag questions in I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]